[Music]
hey guys it's bobby lieber coming to you
from the future home of the lgbtq plus
museum everyone is really excited and
totally getting along
this happens to be my sexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in march
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week
so what's happening didn't you guys have
an announcement this is a little
unexpected but we are in a throuple
situation you're in a trouble
[Music]
let me tell you what's progressive now
being alone i love my life i love my
freedom i love my independence that's
kind of sad that i don't want to be in a
throuple i don't even want to be in a
couple
[Music]
bobby i had sex with that 65 year old
jesus he's rich i don't know it's like
they injected steroids into dumbledore
oh my god that's aaron
he's very hot
gay guys are so stupid i know but we've
been smart enough to brand ourselves as
being smart it's our little secret
[Music]
you met a guy i don't think i'm his type
he's like gay tom brady what are you
into one of these ripped idiots with no
opinions no i'd like someone who's
physically very frail and won't stop
talking
and i bet he's as intimidated by you as
you are by him i'm down for whatever
yeah i can do whenever and i can do
whatever cool whatever whenever gif of
michael scott dancing office gif this
person isn't gay
[Music]
i need you to be honest with me you like
these growing meat head idiots they're
fighting do you like that i can be tough
like your boys oh that's what you like
[Music]
now i have to go to a pride party and
you're both too old to be in the pool
please leave
people are threatening to boycott the
museum you can't say lincoln was gay if
we don't do this we're letting the
heterosexual terrorists win there are
trans terrorists too caitlyn jenner
you're so different from me you're very
intense i like to keep things chill i
can be chill just like a manly man
what's up what's up i got you yeah you
don't need something okay i'm gonna need
some help
what is going on with you my whole life
i've prided myself on being self-reliant
but this guy has gone into my head
maybe you're both bottoms and that's the
problem
game sex was more fun when straight
people were uncomfortable with it
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
[Music]
bye